نعود الى طهران الان مع مراثنا علي الباشا
علي هل تسمعني الان
نعم نعم علي كنت ساقول ان وكاله تسنيم
اكدت اعدام السلطات اليوم لمحتجن اودين
باصابه حارس
بسكين هل هو التنفيذ الاول اا ربما
للاعدام غادات التي تجهدها البلاد
الاول لكنه الشخص لكنه احد همم احد احد
عشر شخصا تم الحكم عليه حتى الان بالاعدام
خمسه اشخاص من التهاميم التعامل مع جهاز
الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي بسبب هدفه نشر
الفوضى في الشارع الايراني والتمرير
المؤامرات التي وصفت هنا بالمؤامرات
الاستقباليه التي تستهدف الامن والاستقرار
في الشارع الايراني هناك سته اشخاص ايضا
متهمين همم بتنفيذ عمليات اغتيال او قتل
همم ناصر البسيج الحرس الثوري واغلاق
الطرق والمرات هذا الشخص الذي تم تنفيذ
الحكم اليوم صباحا بحقه همم متهم باغلاق
احد الطرق هنا في طهران من خلال حرق سلات
المهملات ومن ثم الطعام همم احد همم عناصر
القوى الامنيه بالسكين الى وفاته لاحقا
نعم علي الباشا ماذا عن مظاهر الاحتجاج
بعد ثلاثه ايام من الاضراب هل من المتوقع
استمرار مظاهر الاحتجاج هذه في ايران
يعني الدعوه هي كانت لثلاثه ايام فقط هذا
الاضراب اراده المعارضون ان يكون عاما
يشمل كافه الاسواق في ايران ارادت الحكومه
الايرانيه ان لا يكون اطلاقا معامله جيده
على ذلك من خلال سياسه الترغيب والتحذير
احيانا اخرى لكن الذي حصل ذلك كان هناك
يضرب يمكن ان نقول انه الجزئي يقول جزئي
لانه لم يشمل الاسواق غير المركزيه
والرئيسيه هنا في العاصمه الايرانيه طيران
لكن الصور التي تم تداولها عبر مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي في الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه تثبت ان طيفا من التجار في عده
مدن ومحافظات ايرانيه لم يمارسن نشاطاتهم
التجاريه على مدار الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
غير مختلفين بالاخبار التي توتر وتفيد بان
السلطات الايرانيه قامت بتجميل حسابات
مصرفيه لعشرات التجار الذين امتنعوا عن
همم استئناف نشاطاتهم التجاريه في الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه وقام بتشميعه ايضا المحال
التجاريه او عدد من المحلات التجاريه التي
امتنعت عن ممارسه نشاطتها التجاريه في
الايام مع الثلاثه همم الماضيه وفي
انعكاسات هذا الاضراب هي عوده المظاهرات
ولو بشكل جزئيا الى الشوارع والجماعات
الايرانيه السلطات الايرانيه بعد ان تمكنت
في الايام القليله الماضيه بفعل تجديد
القبضه الامنيه من منع تشكل هذه المظاهرات
في الشوارع في عدد كبير من المدن
والمحافظات الايرانيه لن تتمكن من همم
اكمال مسيرتها يوم امس بعد في في اليوم
الثالث همم اضراب الذي تمت الدعوه له
واستجاب له طيف من التجار في عدد من المدن
والمحافظات الايرانيه كان هناك مظاهرات
شاهدتها وصلت صورها عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي في عدد من الجامعات الايرانيات
داخل العاصمه الايراني وخارج العاصمه
الايراني في عدد من المحافظات الرئيسيه
هنا في طهران كان هناك ايضا مظاهراتهم وان
كانت صغيره ومحدوده العدد في عدد من المدن
والمحافظات الايرانيه ومن بينها العاصمه
الايرانيه طهران تمكنت القوه الامنيه من
افريقيا لكن تشكل هذه المظاهرات همم يشير
الى امكانيات عوده ظهرت الى الشارع
الايراني كما في الايام الاولى همم ربما
في الساعه المقبله علي الباشا مراسلنا من
طهران شكرا لك على كل هذه التوضيحات